it's not what you did you double
jeopardy if somebody's having a stroke
you call 9-1-1 that's not what you did
okay what about you george
well i would have to admit i'm doubly
biased why because one i have a nightly
ritual where i will tape my mouth so i
breathe out of my nose
and that is always when my wife will
start asking questions she can be sound
asleep and then she'll like start a
conversation with me and i have to like
try to like talk out of the side of my
mouth you tape your mouth every night
yeah it actually forces you to nose
breathe instead of mouth breathe and
it's very healthy it's better for you to
nose breathing it's better until unless
you're trying to have a conversation
yeah also clearly occur tomorrow i wish
you had the apparatus on now anyway
and the second reason
is i too
an airpod pro
i dropped my airpod case right before
going on a weekend trip yeah right
outside of my car yeah
i found one
two weeks of like i didn't i searched
for a half an hour could not find the
other one for two weeks i thought it
would show up in my driveway did not
show up i had to buy a new one so i too
would feel the pain yeah of losing also
it's not like it's it's it's airpods are
expensive yes they are you're talking
about 300 i had to buy one
on on ebay for like the whole yeah it's
like the half the cost of a whole airpod
thing well you just bought one yeah
by the whole thing
well i had one left and the case yeah
but the all right
good job
i don't know i don't know about that one
so i'm on your side bobby
right here yeah yeah thank you so much
george you might want to reconsider
being on his side because like he's not
that nice to you yeah yeah right now it
doesn't matter
the judge doesn't have to like the
[ __ ] you know i mean the truth the
truth truths oh that is true i don't
know what that means but anyway um
i believe in the right i guess
yes
yes yes yes yes um because i believe
though it's probably one of the sickest
i've ever been
oh really yeah i do believe that i mean
i believe it is similar to a cold it's
not like anything it's like
it's in the same ballpark in terms of i
wouldn't say cold cold
and i've only had the flu maybe once or
twice